MINDS.
THEY SAY WHEN ARE THEY VOTING ON
USMCA.
IT AFFECTS MY FATHER AND I'M
FALLING ASLEEP, THIS INCREDIBLE
WITNESS TURNS OUT TO BE NOT SO
CREDIBLE.
I'VE GOT TO TELL THE TRUTH, I'M
GOING TO BE AN HONEST DEALER IN
THIS UNLIKE THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW FROM
CAPITOL HILL, HE WAS THE START
OF TODAY'S HEARINGS CONGRESSMAN
JIM JORDAN.
THIS IS MADNESS WE ARE NOW
LIVING THROUGH, THEY WANT US TO
IGNORE THE WHISTLE-BLOWER,
HEARSAY WHO DOESN'T QUALIFY TO
BE A WHISTLE-BLOWER, THAT'S
NUMBER 1.
THE CONTACT WITH THE CONGENITAL
LAWYER'S OFFICE, NOBODY IN THE
COUNTRY BELIEVES THE CONGENITAL
LIAR.
HERE'S THE NEXT STEP, HOW DO YOU
IGNORE HUNTER AND JOE?
THE QUID PRO QUO.
>> YOUR EXACTLY RIGHT, SEAN.
THIS IDEA THAT ADAM SCHIFF
INITIALLY SAID THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS GOING TO
TESTIFY AND NOW HE SAYS HE'S NOT
BECAUSE SOMETHING IN BETWEEN --
WHAT HAPPENED IS THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER CAME TO HIS
OFFICE AND WE FOUND THAT OUT AND
NOW HE SAYS I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHO THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IS.
>> Sean: I'M WATCHING YOU
EVERY DAY AND I'M WATCHING ALL
OF THESE WITNESSES -- WE CAN GO
THROUGH IT ALL.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, AREN'T
THEY ALL JUST COMMENTING ON THE
SAME TRANSCRIPT?
IS THERE ANYONE WHO IS ADDED ANY
SINGLE THING BEYOND THEIR OWN
INTERPRETATION OF THE TRANSCRIPT
INTERPRETATION OF THE TRANSCRIP?
>> THE TRANSCRIPT SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF AND SEVERAL PEOPLE SAID
THIS IN USE AT ALL THE TIME --
THERE ARE FOUR FUNDAMENTAL FACTS
THAT WILL NEVER CHANGE, HAVE
NEVER CHANGED, WILL NEVER
CHANGE.
>> Sean: EXPLAIN THEM SLOWLY.
GO SLOW.
>> WE GOT THE TRANSCRIPT THAT
SHOWS NO LINKAGE, NO PRESSURE,
NO CONDITIONALITY, NO "DO
INVESTIGATION TO GET SECURITY
ASSISTANCE DOLLARS."
WE HAVE THE TWO GUYS WHO WERE ON
THE CALL, THEY BOTH SAID THERE
WAS NO CONDITIONALITY, NO
LINKAGE, NO PRESSURE, NOTHING.
THEN WE HAVE THE FACT THAT
UKRAINIANS DIDN'T KNOW THAT
EIGHT HAD BEEN HELD UP AT THE
TIME OF THE CALL, AND BOTH OUR
WITNESSES TODAY SAID THEY DIDN'T
KNOW UNTIL LATE AUGUST, AUGUST
AUGUST 29TH WITH THE POLITICO
ARTICLE.
FINALLY THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IS THE UKRAINIANS DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING, NO PROMISE, NO
STATEMENT, NO INVESTIGATION,
NONE OF IT.
THOSE FACTS WILL NOT CHANGE,
THEY HAVE TO STIR IT ALL UP AND
SAY SOMEONE SAID TO SOMEONE ELSE
AND HERE I AM, THAT'S WHAT THEIR
CASE IS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THROUGH
IT, THEY KNOW THE FACTS ARE ON
THE PRESIDENT'S SIDE IN THIS
PROCESS IS ENTIRELY UNFAIR.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU BIFURCATE
YOUR BRAIN IS A DEMOCRAT WHICH
I'M ASKING EVERYBODY, HOW IS IT
POSSIBLE JOE BIDEN IS ON TAPE
"FIRE THE PROSECUTOR?"
WHY WOULD A VICE PRESIDENT EVER
WANT TO FIRE A PROSECUTOR IN
UKRAINE -- "OR YOU'RE NOT
GETTING THE MONEY UNLESS YOU DO
THE ACT."
HE WAS WARNED THE PROSECUTOR WAS
INVESTIGATING HIS SON WITH ZERO
EXPERIENCE AND PAID MILLIONS,
FIRE HIM, YOU GET A BILLION,
DON'T FIRE HIM, YOU DON'T GET A
BILLION, THAT SOUNDS A GOOD
SHAKEDOWN BRIBERY, A SQUID, A
PRO, QUO AND A AND THEY DON'T
WANT US TO BRING THAT UP, IT IS
BREATHTAKING HYPOCRISY.
>> HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE, THIS
SUNDAY NANCY PELOSI CALLED
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON IMPOSTER, THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE CALLING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
ON IMPOSTER, THAT'S WHAT DRIVES
ALL OF THIS.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE NEVER
ACCEPTED THE FACT THAT
63 MILLION AMERICANS VOTED FOR
THIS GUY AND THEY WANT TO COME
HERE AND SHAKE IT UP AND HE WON
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE LANDSLIDE
AND THEY DON'T CARE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T TRUST THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS REALLY ALL
ABOUT AND THEY ARE TRYING TO
WITH AN ANONYMOUS WHISTLE-BLOWER
WITH NO FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE WHO
WORKED WITH JOE BIDEN, WHO
EVERYONE KNOWS WHO THIS GUY IS
BUT HE WON'T TELL US -- THEY ARE
TRYING TO TAKE OUT OF PRESIDENT
11 AND A HALF MONTHS BEFORE THE
NEXT ELECTION AND THAT'S WHAT
DRIVES AMERICANS CRAZY.
YOU ARE RIGHT AND DON JR. IS